the Joe Rogan experience it's like I was
I'm actually like a little nervous about
telling athletes that they should smoke
weed now like that's that's
nerve-racking because like your whole
dependent you're dependent on your
underboss in the place you work and
thing you do right so just saying
something like that if two people find
that offensive and they raise enough how
sure that's a big [ __ ] deal
but what we're just saying is like it's
better than vicodin it's better than
Hills it's it's it's a very much
healthier alternative alternative well
you know what it is man it's a tool it's
like you can abuse tools but you could
also use them correctly you mean you
don't want to [ __ ] hammer nails with
a saw right but but if you use marijuana
correctly and you have discipline and
you know what you're doing the problem
is that it's been illegal for so long
people don't understand what the best
way to use it for is and what are the
side effects what is the you know what's
the paranoia what's this heightened
sense of awareness that kind of freaks
people out like how do you how do you
mitigate that how do you how do you get
over what's the right dosage all that
stuff is dependent upon information and
when people are lying to you about it
being terrible and you know making you
[ __ ] blind and losing your marbles
you're gonna kill people yeah this stuff
people are so confused about it that it
also makes you more paranoid because as
you're smoking you thinking oh my god I
shouldn't be doing this right what am i
doing I'm ruining my life I can't
believe it doing that then you get even
more paranoid and then you're like I'm
never doing this again exactly yeah yeah
now what about sponsors is it ever an
issue with sponsors the weed thing where
would be right now the only people I
work with other than myself is that an
analytical solution so he's actually
working on doing the CBD thing and stuff
um I don't know if I'll be a part of
that because I'm trying to there's it's
so available now I just I'd rather just
find whoever does it the very best and
not not marketing right it's so
saturated I just take it for myself
actually a lot of people I I worked in
group homes when I was in college for
kids with autism
for for a long time and there was
actually this little girl who she had
this this it's not a disease she had
this I'll just call it a thing she had
this thing where she always felt like
she was falling so I'm so like she
looked completely normal she was
autistic and nonverbal didn't speak but
imagine all day feeling like you're
falling so she learned as a child really
little if she would hit herself that
people would hold her so if you weren't
holding her she would literally she
watched her break her own nose and she
was she was 11 years old this this sweet
little girl like just super nice and
smiley but like if you didn't hold her
she just walked right in her own face
and we found out that through I don't
remember exactly how it came about but
they they gave her THC pills they gave
her THC pills and then stopped she would
walk around the house normally like she
was still nonverbal it's not like I
fixed her autism or any of that stuff
but with the whole symptoms of feeling
like she was falling which I'm sure I
don't even think had anything to do with
autism again I'm not a doctor but [ __ ]
so uh would they gave her THC pills and
she was like just walking around the
house smiling she would help us cook she
would move around like she would help
the other kids cuz there's four kids in
the house she would help the other kids
tie their shoes stuff like that that's
true some then her parents came back
must have been four months later and
their friends had guilted them about
giving her dog their daughter weed and
they stopped giving it to her and she
went right back to it straight back to
it it's so stupid it's just ignorant
people just don't understand what it is
it's all it is yeah
oh that's so sad I felt so bad it's one
of the things that like just ripped me
apart from working in that field is just
just there's so much like there's these
little rules that you don't understand
we had a kid that would sit right and he
would just he would feel stressed out
and he would sit and the rule was when
he did that we weren't allowed to help
him up or move him or anything like that
because that was rewarding bad behavior
that's how they classified that so he
would just sit in the middle of the road
and we weren't allowed to get him out of
the middle of the road he would he was
and then he learned that if he didn't
want to do something if he basically
would stay in his room
all day he would stay in his room all
day because he didn't like the only
worker he liked was me and I think it
was just because I was big and jolly and
all that but if he didn't like the
person he was working with he just sit
in his room on the floor and then they
couldn't touch him they couldn't do
anything he just sit there
he'd go days without eating or going
anywhere out of the room or anything
like that and it was all because we'd
put these rules in and put these chains
on ourselves based off of other people's
opinions our worrying what it would look
like if we did this you know if this
girl's taking this pill what does that
look like or if we're picking this boy
up off the ground what does that look
like and it was it was it was it was
like trying to help these children with
your hands tied behind your back
and I don't know if it's like that
anymore it was this was a long time ago
but it was just it was heartbreaking
emember everyone was terrified to work
with this little boy he was 10 or 11
he's just a sweet little dude he just
didn't he got nervous you know and so I
remember coming in and one day I was
like you know what I'm taking him to go
to a football game so I took him to a
college division 1 football game never
had an issue never had any problems
never sat down nothing
sat second-row in the endzone and like
would get all excited every time anybody
came by like the the cannon went off for
a touchdown it was like the greatest
moment of my whole like college career
was hanging out with this 11 year old at
a college football game and people were
too terrified to even get out of his
room that's terrible that's so cool you
got him there though yeah I'd like to
think that a lot of people work more in
that direction after I left you know I'm
hoping then she was you could see in his
eyes he was a sweet little boy you know
you know you
there's I've never met a kid that was
evil ever you just need to know how to
work with him how to talk with him
[Applause]